Cô nội vụ cho biết tính đến ngày 15 tháng bẩy,
có tảm mấy lâm nghỉ 1,5 bộ mấy bẩy cán mộ,
công chức, bên chức, người là động trong các cơ quan.
Tổ chức, đơn vị của đảng,
nhà nước, mà chận tổ quốc Việt Nam và các tổ chức chính chị
xa hội từ chung đếng cơ sở và lực lượng vũ trang đã có quy định nghỉ việc.
Hưởng chính sách,
chế độ thang nghị định số 1,5 năm,
hành hủ chăm 20 tư và nghị định số 1,5 năm, hành hủ chăm 20,5 cộ chính phủ.
Xong người đang chính cấp có thầm quyền phy dịch kinh phí và số người đã được cấp có thầm quyền phy dịch kinh phí
là bẩy mấy tư nghiên 2,5 bộ mấy tả người.
Trong đó,
2,5 niệm 4,5 bẩy người đang chính cấp có thầm quyền phy dịch kinh phí.
5,5 năm,
3,8 mộ người đã được cấp có thầm quyền phy dịch kinh phí.
Trong đó,
xong người đã được nhận tiền là 1,5 nghị của 3,5 nghệ,
chiếm tỷ lệ bẩy mấy xau phy 2,5 năm.
Bộ nội vụ đang tích tục theo dõi,
đồn đốc giải quyết kỳ thời,
đầy đủ chế độ,
chính sách cho đổi ngủ cạnh mộ,
công chức bên chức nghĩ chế độ giò sợ xếp theo quy định.